this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
hi everybody thank you so much for
coming out for this talk I'm really just
excited to be back on campus back at
Cornell surrounded by so many familiar
faces and friends and really thrilled
that even so many more of you had
interest in the topic of conversation
today and felt like joining us so for
any of you who have done some work with
the New York State Department of
Agriculture in the past you'll hopefully
appreciate the title of this talk
connecting the dots our Commissioner
Richard ball has a habit of saying
connecting the dots in just about every
talk he gives so it felt very
appropriate that I that I echo that and
mirror that here but really when I was
interviewing for this job which I've
only actually just hit my three-year
anniversary with the state so hurray but
when I was interviewing with the for
this job it was very clear to me that
the work that was being done we had a
small team in Brooklyn it had gone
through a lot of transition pretty
recently and the department was really
seeking some people with vision to kind
of figure out how can we best leverage
our presence there what should we be
doing in sort of an urban environment to
support the statewide agricultural
industries and so this question came up
a lot are you able to connect that's how
how are you gonna connect all these dots
so hopefully you'll get a sense of how
we're doing that today from an urban
food systems perspective um so early you
know in not not too long ago I think
there was a general idea that a lot of
what urban foods what urban systems
could offer to the kind of food movement
or agricultural industries was that it
was really becoming hot and trendy to
buy local right farmers markets were
really exciting farmers markets seemed
exciting for lots of reasons one it's
you know raising awareness in urban
environments but also creating a direct
market channel for our farmers so that
they can cut out a lot of middlemen and
just make a little bit more on on the
crops that they're selling and so early
stages of what this office has done if
anybody remembers Bob Lewis
he was a pretty formative figure in
helping to figure out and navigate the
bureaucracies of New York City zoning
regulations and community board
engagements and figuring out how we
actually support the proliferation
of farmers markets in New York City so
we now are home to one of the largest
green market or one of the largest
farmers market systems in the country
which is great thanks to our partners at
Green Market that's still very much a
piece of the puzzle here but it's less
of the work that we're doing today so I
just want to call that out is really
important part and the farm-to-table
movement is another space that I think
you know in the earlier years of sort of
this rebirth of a local food movement
was was very promising for a local
producers getting chefs very excited
about local foods really reclaiming sort
of regional foods and celebrating them
still an important part of the puzzle
but we're not just doing farm-to-table
stuff anymore I think our work has
expanded pretty significantly so before
I get into kind of the nitty gritty and
nuts and bolts of what I do on a day to
day basis I thought you even though you
just heard my bio it'd be helpful to
give you a little bit more context of
just who I am and what other hats I wear
because I think this informs not only
the work that we're doing at the
department just sort of my understanding
of how the urban food systems work in
how we connect with different partners
around the five boroughs in particular
so you already know I work for the New
York State Department of Ag of markets I
head up our tiny team down there in
Brooklyn we're just five and I'll get
into a sort of how we fit within the
larger department in just a moment but
outside of that I'm a you know a whole
person that really cares a lot about
food and farming in other ways so I am a
community gardener and I also run our
compost program I've been through the
New York City master compost training
program which is yes that's a thing we
have we don't have a master gardener but
we have a master composter program super
cool I also am a student and instructor
at something called farm school NYC
farm school is a popular education model
it's sort of in each one teach one kind
of thing where folks who work in the
fields of urban AG in various capacities
can offer to teach classes to help their
colleagues and peers just develop their
own skills and and you know do a better
job of whatever they're trying to
achieve
so within farm school I teach a class
called Enterprise so I'm working with
folks who are entrepreneurs or
entrepreneurial in some endeavor they
want to get a project or some initiative
off the ground it could look like a
social movement it could look like I
want to start a community garden
like I want to start a plant-based queer
POC own catering company it could be all
of these things and so these are the
folks that I get into my class and in
farm school and get a real sense of like
what cool things are happening on the
front line which is really awesome you
heard a little bit in my bio that I also
did a lot of ontraport with
entrepreneurs in my role at hot fried
kitchen is anybody in here heard of a
kitchen incubator before is that a
couple people okay so a kitchen
incubator real estate is really
expensive in New York City if you want
to start your own you know beverage
business hot sauce business cookie
business whatever the rent that you're
gonna pay just to get a legally
licensable kitchen is insane
entrepreneurship is scary enough margins
and food are thin enough it's not it's a
big barrier to entering the industry so
hot bread kitchen and many others across
the the city and state are creating
what's called incubator spaces their
shared commercial kitchen spaces we had
a 3,000 square foot commercial kitchen
that we would rent out to anywhere
between 120 food businesses per year and
help them navigate all the fun ins and
outs of licensing start-up costs
sourcing finding packaging all the fun
stuff still a network that I stay very
closely connected to in my my current
role and I'm very grateful for that and
then of course shoutout to Cornell I'm
an alum go big red and Here I am putting
my SEPA degree to work ray in public
government it works it really happened
so glad that that worked out for me so
just wanted to share that with all of
you so you have a sense of who I am and
what experience I'm walking in the room
with let's get into the work alright so
how many folks in the room no absolutely
clearly what the New York State
Department of Agriculture does nobody
good I didn't either
we do a lot of things so one of the
things that you know government
bureaucracies they're difficult to
navigate or to wrap your head around so
I thought a little context here might
also be helpful for our conversation
today and the New York State Department
of Ag markets through its various
divisions of which there are 15 you have
15 different divisions so through our
various divisions and programs we
promote New York agriculture
and it's high-quality and diverse
products we foster agricultural
environmental stewardship and safeguard
the state's food supply land and
livestock to ensure the viability and
growth of New York's agricultural
industries so largely we're a regulatory
agency that's what this kind of
translates to most of the work that the
agency does in our various divisions is
overseeing things like food safety if
you're moving animals across state lines
onto farms in New York State we want to
inspect them same with plants if you're
bringing plants in from other places
countries states wherever we do a lot of
just sort of preventative regulatory
functions to make sure that we're not
bringing diseases and all that fun stuff
into our agricultural industries but one
just one of our 15 divisions is focused
on what's called agricultural
development this is where all the fun
stuff happens this is my sort of parent
division that oversees our department
and this is where we do things like
market orders this is where we do things
like grant funding for nonprofits who
are doing food access work this is where
we fund things like nutrition incentive
programs and fun you know health folks
are not health bugs though nutrition
bucks that you can spend at farmer's
markets it's also where we do a lot of
promotional stuff so if anybody in the
room has seen like taste New York
branding or the New York run and
certified programming those sort of buy
local campaigns they live within the
same division as me agricultural
development all right so where does
Urban come in there's a lot of
challenges in New York State and those
of you who work very closely with our
farmers probably know there's a much
longer list of challenges than the three
of bullets I have listed here but for
the sake of argument we'll start with
three and in the state of New York we
have a couple of challenges when it
comes to really supporting our farmers
across the state and particularly our
rural farmers one the high cost of doing
business in New York New York is a very
expensive place to do business which
means that by default our prices are
generally higher this has tremendous
impact on who's willing and able to
purchase food that comes from New York
so that's a challenge we face and trying
to help
our local farmers and agricultural
producers across the state is dealing
with we know we're not usually gonna be
the lowest price bidder
that's generally the case also most of
our farms are small I wish on you are
here to give me the exact number but
it's well over ninety percent of our
farms across the state are considered
small farms by the news I by the USDA so
small farms mean they probably don't
have a whole big team to manage their
distribution that's often the farmer or
the producer themselves having to deal
with a lot of distribution it makes it
really hard to get food around the state
and we're quite a big state and we also
have quite a lot of geographic diversity
so you know if you're farming over here
in Essex County and just trying to get
your stuff over here to Jefferson County
there's a little thing called the
Adirondacks in the way and it's just
kind of actually challenging was
logistically to get food moving around
the state an access to market similarly
is a challenge particularly for smaller
farms who again have to take on that
burden of marketing and distributing
their products often themselves or with
a small team so all of those challenges
plus many others make it difficult for
our farmers to gain access to the people
who want to buy their which there are
increasingly a lot of people who want to
buy local which is great one thing that
I know we've talked a lot about sort of
within the industry is sort of this
promise of food hubs and using sort of
aggregation as a mechanism to help the
small farms kind of create a scale that
is able to plug into institutional
purchasers or wholesale buyers and I
don't know how many of you saw but there
is a study put out just at the beginning
of this year that did sort of an
assessment of what's the population
needed to create a viable breakeven for
at least one food hub they seem kind of
like a hot policy solution right now so
everybody's really excited about hubs
and want to build hubs everywhere
but what this paper kind of showed is
that you really do need a critical mass
of people in order to purchase from a
food hub to make it financially viable
as a you know business endeavor so we
took some of that data and I think the
threshold was 182 thousand people per
county was was the base minimum of what
you wanted to have in order to create
like a viable food hub
so we took those numbers and we did a
quick map of them and lo and behold what
you find anybody recognize what these
green counties tend to be hung to
anybody cities exactly cities so cities
we it's it's very like intuitive right
cities have population density we have
people we have eaters we also have lots
of feeding programs we have institutions
where people are staying and being fed
like hospitals for a long time so
there's a lot of purchasing power within
cities that's not the only thing that we
offer to the agricultural industry but
it is an important one and I thought
this map just did such a nice job of
really just making that very clear and
obvious it's not just New York City by
the way there are cities across the
state that what as we better understand
their food systems in each area we can
better leverage them to support everyone
that's surrounding them which are all of
our rural producers across the state ok
so what is it that my team actually does
urban food systems or the Brooklyn team
as we're often called so don't get us
confused we are one in the same we are a
tiny team looking at how food is
produced in transported to and
distributed around cities to understand
how that system impacts the health
wealth and well-being of city
inhabitants as well as urban and rural
food and farm businesses it's kind of a
mouthful but if you can kind of get you
know your head around it it's the system
thinking we want to see the ways that
food is moving across cities and ask the
questions as to why it's moving that way
and what we can do to shift that if it's
not moving in a way that's beneficial to
everyone so how do we do that here's how
we're here's where the rubber hits the
road here's how we're connecting the
dots we as a small team have quite a
portfolio I'm gonna walk through a
little bit of it and feel free to jump
in with some maybe like clarifying
questions here just cuz I'm not going to
get into all of this stuff in the next
couple of slides but just to kind of
paint you the picture we have a couple
of formal programs and then a bunch of
stuff that we sort of informally are
doing just because we sort of get called
on or tasked with doing it because we
sit in the city center so marketplace
development for example
we don't run the marketing programs
ourselves but our department does right
so we often lend a support that's one of
our sort of informal programs what we do
in marketplace development though much
like Bob Lewis who played such an
important role in helping to create the
green market system and helping farmers
get access to that marketplace we're
looking for what comes next we're sort
of hitting a saturation point maybe in
terms of farmers markets in the city
we're running out of places to put them
where there's viable foot traffic and
interest and so we need to look at other
ways to leverage the population density
and demand within cities to support our
farmers and procurement is sort of a
really exciting space right now
everybody's kind of looking at how you
can pull Weaver's of institutional food
purchasing and shift that to support
local so we're doing a lot of research
in there I'll get into that one a little
bit more in a future in a future slide
supply chain development is always just
a question that's not a formal program
that we run but always a question that
we're thinking about because of that
aggregation sort of hub map that we
talked about we feel like we need to be
really mindful of what the actual supply
chain infrastructure is it helps us
achieve this goal of getting food into
our cities and getting it moving it
around
are there enough hubs to aggregate is
there enough processing if the schools
that we're working with want ground beef
do we have someone in New York State
that can do that for the dairy cows that
we want to call and turn into beef often
we don't but asking these questions is a
really important part of the food
systems perspective of asking like if we
have we know we have producers with this
product we know we have demand for this
product but what are all the places it
has to move through in order to get to
us in the spec and form that we needed
it urban producers urban growers is sort
of a very broad term that encompasses
both urban farmers as well as community
gardens we do have sort of a gray area
of distinction between them there's sort
of a subtle distinction between them in
some spaces but we at the department do
believe that you know farmers are
farmers and if you're trying to
commercially grow food awesome plug into
Cornell make sure you're getting all the
help you need to be commercially viable
but if you're also just a community lead
initiative there's a lot of merits
attitude
called the office of urban or sorry the
office of community gardens that does
kind of just light touch look out for
the well-being of community gardens I'd
love that to be more robust so if
anybody knows any money out there that
we can fund community gardens please let
me know we'll go get it every think we
should be fun in that work but we we do
a lot of technical assistance for these
folks for the growers and also for local
food processors a lot of the challenges
that people face in kind of the early
startup days is understanding like
regulations right what do I have to put
on my label do I have to keep this
refrigerated if I write that it's ready
to eat what does that mean what kind of
kitchen do I need to use if I just want
to slice something there's not a real
great internet rabbit hole you can fall
down to find all that information very
clearly you'll fall down rabbit holes
very much clear information so we try to
be a little bit of a navigator in that
space and just kind of work with
startups across the city and make sure
they understand how to be in compliance
so they're not going to get slapped with
fines or shut down
down the line and then the scaling food
businesses work that we do is really
about working with the startups who've
now kind of hit their stride they're
looking to move up or step out as we
tend to refer to it as and step out
space they want to expand they want to
increase their production they often
don't know where to go to find land
particularly if they're looking to get
out of New York City let's say you're a
farmer and you want to even farming in
the Bronx and you feel really good about
it but you want to get up into Orange
County or Dutchess County you're
probably not plugged in to a lot of the
resources that are more rural farmers
are familiar with right you might not
know FSA because FSA does not have a
presence in New York City you might not
know well you might not have known CCE
but now we have a presence there you
might not know that American Farmland
trust and the farmland navigator tools
that are out there are really accessible
and something you can use to help find
the land that you want to purchase so we
try to be that conduit and kind of that
node of connecting folks who've been
living and working in New York City but
maybe you want to moved further afield
up into the state I'm like how to do
that introducing them to folks that can
help the food access programs is
something
I think we've been doing for a little
while we've sort of had a bit of a
nutrition mandate at the Department
mostly in this space the nutrition
assistance anybody who I referenced our
Farmers Market nutrition program earlier
those are dollars that if you are if you
have snap if you can if you have a snap
card or food stamps that you can spend
swipe that at a farmers market and get
some additional bucks to spend that
increase your purchasing power to help
lower-income folks better access healthy
fruits and vegetables and local foods so
that program has been in existence for
quite a long time I think what we're
really excited about right now in New
York City is that we're really expanding
and rethinking that work particularly
from an equity lens so I don't know how
many folks are familiar with using that
term but in equity lens we kind of see
that as underpinning all of the work we
do but it really matters probably the
most within our food access space which
is looking for ways to acknowledge
inequities and in justices that have
existed in our country our city and our
boroughs for a very long time to named
that whether it be racism sexism
whatever other kind of ism to identify
named that and then plan around it think
about it as how it factors into the work
that we're doing so in places like
Brooklyn which we'll get into in just a
moment where there's a lot of historical
inequities that have created a food
system that is largely dis serving most
of the people who live there how do we
begin to think about improving that
system if we don't also name and look at
race explicitly so that I think is a
pretty exciting area of work for us in
our team and food box we'll talk about
as well that's a specific program the
last kind of pillar of our portfolio
here is thinking about the industry
future so this is something that's a
little wonky it's a little like not
formal programs that we run but things
that the department has tasked us with
doing as sort of a small young team with
a lot of policy training and analysis
training they've asked us to do things
like support our effort to be more
approachable to new in beginning farmers
which is great
I don't know how many of the younger
folks in the room have gone out in tag
spaces and then like wow there's a lot
of old white men in suits here and
that's fine that's fine but that's not
always very inviting or inclusive to a
lot of young folks you're trying to get
into the industry and so having a
perspective of like how are we talking
about our work to youth how are we
getting people excited about careers in
food and agriculture and then plugging
them into the resources to get started
on that path so that's something that
lives with us really that just means
we're building a website right now so
not the most exciting thing but I'm
hopeful that we will continue to push
that work a little bit further as time
goes by we do a lot of policy research
and development just out of the nature
of kind of specifically who we have on
the team and then we're very excited
about rolling in some youth engagement
work this is another piece of the puzzle
that I think makes a lot of sense to
live within the urban food system
particularly in New York City you may
not have a sense of this unless you're
working kind of very closely with with
New York City but youth gardening
farming food justice agriculture this
whole world this whole space is like the
momentum behind it right now is kind of
incredible and unstoppable and we just
feel like we should be at the table for
stuff to steward some of that so in and
around New York City we've got about 750
I want to say school-based gardens these
are gardens that are mostly coming out
of a science teacher or you know some
other particular individual in the
school who says wouldn't it be cool if
we had a garden and could talk to kids
about how to how to grow food what's
happening in those holes though is that
they're getting kids really excited
about food and growing food and talking
about how food access looks different
across different neighborhoods and
they're really engaging in these amazing
conversations about food justice but
they're not talking about agriculture
they're not utilizing things like AG in
the classroom resources or 4-h or FFA
which in the AG world is just like a
given right the kids coming up in sort
of more rural agricultural communities
are just steeped in that stuff from very
early ages so making those connections
and trying to encourage kind of
activities that we see that are really
very much in the vein of the work that
the
Cartman and our agricultural industries
over across the state are looking for
connecting again connecting we're doing
it okay so maybe what we'll do just to
make sure we finish on time is I'm gonna
power through and talk a little bit
about specifically procurement some of
our food access work and then we'll
maybe pause and have questions and if
you want to come back to any of this
stuff that I didn't really get in today
cuz I know we're from across multiple
disciplines and probably have lots of
different interests here
okay so leveraging purchasing power
institutional procurement there's last
slide of this I don't know if we're
going to share this out but I listed
some of the papers that I pulled this
stuff from if you're interested in some
follow up reading purchasing power is
huge and I think I forgot to write down
the number but I think New York State
alone spends almost nine hundred and
ninety million dollars a year on food
across the state that's a lot of money
if you look at the breakdown here
largely that falls into there's like
three areas in which state dollars are
public dollars I should say are buying
food we're feeding people who are food
insecure largely through our Department
of Health and child and adult care food
programs there's a lot of people
utilizing emergency food assistance
which is all always government-funded
it's federal it's state there's often
city buckets the the pour into that as
well oh god I'm not gonna be able to
answer that question yeah this is also
there's someone on my team who's sort of
our expert in this and I take like the
high level tip of the iceberg from her
so I don't know but it's big money and
it's feeding a lot of people right so
one of the things that kind of becomes
apparent within this space obviously
schools and hospitals down here at the
bottom where we're feeding public people
who are being fed by publicly funded
institutions there's kind of two
opportunities here right one is that we
can shift some percentage of that nine
hundred million dollars a year to better
support our local
agricultural producers but when you also
look at the volume of people that you're
serving you know three million eaters a
year coming through emergency food
assistance there's over a million meals
served a day in New York City public
schools New York City public schools
serve breakfast and lunch and so for a
lot of our kids who are coming from food
insecure communities which sadly it's a
lot and that's two-thirds of their like
nutritional content for the day and
that's coming from government purchased
food so we have both the opportunity to
shift where were who we're buying from
to make a local economic impact but also
to think about the health and well-being
people who are eating this food and
making sure that we're providing healthy
and nutritious food which you can't
necessarily draw the line right that
local food is healthier but you can do a
direct connection between local food
often being less processed and less
processed foods are healthier it's
fresher the nutrition content could be a
little higher if it hasn't sat on a
shelf and then shipped you know via rail
across the country so there are some
other benefits that we think about when
we think about moving the needle on
purchasing this kind of food some of the
ways in which we are doing that
specifically because it's a really
difficult thing to even think about
institutional procurement it's all
because it's government money it's very
well regulated in terms of how you can
spend it so some of the challenges that
people face when they're trying to shift
institutional procurement is there's
something in the federal procurement law
that says you are not allowed to specify
place-based preference so you can't say
in your bid I only want to buy from New
York State growers you're spending
federal dollars usually so you are
obligated to take the lowest price that
you get so if you need ten hundred
thousand pounds of carrots and you put
that out for a bid the company that can
bring you ten hundred thousand pounds of
carrots at the lowest price is who
you're gonna buy it from guess how often
that comes from the state of New York
not often enough right so we have to get
creative in how we help these other
government institutions think about how
they purchase their food there are some
really creative ways that hopefully
in the horticultural space you'll you'll
appreciate you can actually specify
varieties of fruits and vegetables that
you want you could say I only want to
buy Snapdragon what what Ruby what
what's the apples that we can only thank
you snap J yeah you can specify those
particular apples no one else is going
to produce those kinds of apples because
only New York State growers who have a
license to produce those apples but you
got to have somebody in your procurement
office who really understands the wonky
AG stuff which does not happen right we
were sitting down with the person who
writes the menus for the New York City
School District she's amazing she has to
calorie count and balance every single
meal that every child in every single
school is being served every day
remember that's a million meals a day
and they have multiple menus they have
the regular menu they have a vegetarian
menu they have a like variety like
different culturally appropriate menus
they have religious menu they have
multiple menus that she's got a balance
every single one of them but she didn't
know for example that like getting a
pumpkin in April means you're probably
not getting it from New York
like the seasonality piece when we grow
food and when we can harvest food when
we have it at a large enough volume to
meet your specs that stuff that the
Department of Ag has in terms of
insights that your typical purchasing
agent in you know Corrections or the
office of mental health probably doesn't
fully know so that's part of where we've
seen some space to carve out and really
do some technical assistance and kind of
help coach people in the food part of
purchasing food and we also are able to
look at procurement bids as a what
mechanism of cost savings so the
emergency food space is particularly
interesting here because this is the big
slice of the pie right a lot of the
money that we're spending on food is
going to food pantries and food banks
and feeding people who are sure in need
those folks tend not to buy local as you
can imagine they're mostly nonprofits
and they're very price sensitive so
again New York State kind of gets shot
in the foot right we can't necessarily
out compete on price what we can do
though using our procurement tools is
hell food pantries do what's called
collective buying
of central contracts which is there are
certain contracts negotiated centralized
at the state level that actually once
they're negotiated in place other
institutions can purchase off of them so
they might have negotiated a price with
a supplier maybe not for their food but
maybe for their paper towels that is
significantly cheaper or their their
plates right that is significantly
cheaper than what the individual food
bank could buy on its own because you've
amassed some purchasing power you've
done some collective buying so if we can
help folks start to buy some of their
other supplies based on central
contracts and collective purchasing it
frees up more of their money the limited
money that they do have to spend on
pricier food which they know will have a
positive economic and impact they do
want to support local farms it's just
about freeing up that money so that they
can spend it alright so let's talk about
food access I mentioned this is a space
that I'm really excited about food
access
we know that community gardens have been
a part of food access for a long time
they're not the only solution certainly
we talked about food pantries there's
lots of other ways that people are being
fed who are in need but I want to lift
up community gardens in particular here
in New York City
you know since 70s and 80s we've been
we've been we bear witness to people who
are occupying land growing food and
taking matters of their health into
their own hands by saying ok well
there's not a place nearby that I can
buy fresh healthy food but I can grow it
so that movement is still alive and very
strong today across the five boroughs
and the state I would argue and what
we're starting to see now you know
people often say to me like well what's
a community garden gonna do they're not
gonna be able to feed everybody right
you can't feed all of New York City on a
community garden level no maybe not but
the secret that I discovered in getting
into this work is that the community
gardens are home to more than just the
gardener's themselves there are kindred
folks there the people who care about
where their food comes from they're the
people who've grown tomatoes and refuse
to buy them from the grocery store
because they know the difference in
quality they know the difference in
flavor they
know the difference in how long
something is gonna last in their home
kitchen when they've just harvested
based on or compared to buying something
that sat on a shelf for weeks and that
translates even in low-income
communities to dollars saved right I'm
not having to throw out my lettuce cuz
I've had it for two days I can keep it
for two weeks because I just harvested
it and that thing's pretty much still
alive even though it's sitting in the
fridge so these are our kindred folks so
what we've started to see at community
gardens is these really innovative
models of improving access to healthy
food not just by growing it but by doing
things like collected buying same
principles apply in the institutional
space right it's a mechanism to bring
price down if you have let's say an
order out to a farm and you want to buy
you know one pound of carrots versus you
can prepay for 30 or 50 you can probably
get a better price per pound on those
carrots there's power and collective in
collective buying and so what these
gardens have started to do is to serve
as a venue for collective buying to
happen they get with their fellow
gardeners who really care about good
food and where it comes from and they
say hey what if we sign up for a CSA but
instead of signing up for one CSA which
could be a couple hundred dollars a
season we commit to 10 or 20 or 50 I bet
we can get our better price per pound
they put that order in to the farms and
bring the food in and they're able to
distribute it at a much lower price than
you could otherwise get at retail so
this is a model that's been happening
kind of in fits and starts in different
parts of the city lo and behold New York
State Ayanna markets got some money to
fund just these kinds of projects we
call them our food box program so we are
now able to turn around and invest in
community lead solutions that we know
are working that makes sense
economically they're viable they don't
need any infrastructure they literally
just set up a tent in a table or they
sell out of the gazebo in the garden and
they're able to also include alongside
some of the food that they're growing
themselves which gives a little bit of
an opportunity to kind of test the
commercial waters for some of our
growers in the city it's also just a
nice add-in it's a great way to
incorporate some culturally relevant
foods
we have gardens all over the city grand
callaloo i don't know a single farmer in
the state of New York that is growing
callaloo but our food boxes in Brooklyn
in all of our heavily Caribbean
neighborhoods have onions and cabbages
and carrots and all the things that New
York State farmers grow but they also
have callaloo they also have long beans
they also have all sorts of really
culturally relevant foods because
they're able to kind of do this hybrid
grow some themselves brings them in from
other farms and then lastly oh good
we're gonna have lots of time for
questions I'm sure we'll have them I
mentioned bringing equity kind of to the
forefront of all the work that we're
doing in part this just feels like it's
2019 we should be doing this anyways but
this is it particularly when you're
working in New York City there's a lot
of history that you have to understand
that have shaped the food system as it
currently looks so anybody know what
this map is on the far left
anybody recognize that map shout it out
if you do it's definitely Brooklyn
they're all Brooklyn a little bit of
Queens here but mostly Brooklyn Brooklyn
Brooklyn
it's a map from 1938 it is called the
home lending map of 19 its redlining
exactly so show of hands anybody
redlining know what it is couple folks
not everybody good okay so redlining
is really insidious urban development
practice that has been in existence for
or was in existence for quite a long
time that very explicitly literally drew
lines around neighborhoods to either
encourage or discourage investment and
that's personal investment in terms of
lending to home purchases or commercial
activity investing in creating
businesses in certain neighborhoods the
map that we're looking at the Green okay
if you can even see there is one
neighborhood in green those are the
neighborhoods that are considered a plus
go go ahead and invest buy a home banks
will lend to you banks will give you
capital to start a business go there and
prosper the neighborhoods that are in
red and in yellow are the bottom of the
barrel they're the ones that had the
least incentives in fact they had
disincentives in place you couldn't get
loans to buy a home there you couldn't
get loans to start a business there and
that even though this is from 1938 has
had a tremendous impact on how New York
City has evolved and specifically how
our food system has evolved so the next
map here in the middle this is from 2000
this is a demographic look at what near
of what Brooklyn look like in 2000 so
far far along and beyond redlining
but what do you notice about the
neighborhoods the red on this map means
african-americans live there the blue is
where white folks live green is where
latina communities live and then Asian
is pink and others are just sort of the
gray mottled look at this this is
Prospect Park this is for those of you
who don't know the map of Brooklyn like
the back here and like I do that's sort
of your marker right there if I knew how
to use this thing there we go
this is Prospect Park this is Greenpoint
this is this helps orient you right this
is Greenpoint Prospect Park all this red
and yellow area where folks were told
you're not going to be eligible for a
loan to buy a home you're not going to
be eligible for a loan to start a
business largely have become communities
of color
that's not accidental they were
communities of color when they were here
too the percentage of people of color
that lived in a neighborhood was one of
the distinguishing characteristics that
the banks used to say whether or not the
community should be eligible for
investment not much has changed in terms
of demographics this map over here this
is from 2002 out this down 2015 this is
a map of child poverty rates in Brooklyn
by community district the darker the red
the higher the rate of childhood poverty
the darkest red is real real dark ones
are 50% or more kids living in poverty
what do you notice about these maps it's
the same areas right
this still impacts all of the work that
we are doing today within our food
access portfolio we were given a really
special project by the governor's office
he had an initiative called the vital
Brooklyn initiative
it's an historic investment 1.4 billion
dollars in the health and well-being of
the folks who live in central Brooklyn
this essential Brooklyn so he asked
state eight different state agencies to
come to the table with some form of
wellness programming to implement in the
same space and time to really tackle
what's called the social determinants of
health we all know that health is a mix
of many factors right it's not just what
you eat or how often you exercise for
what kind of genetics you're born with
it has to do with whether or not you're
breathing in mold spores in your home
whether or not you have access to public
transportation to get to the doctor
whether or not you have truck routes
coming through your communities viewing
all sorts of air contamination whether
or not you are on a former brownfield
and that's been remediated appropriately
all of these social and environmental
factors impact how healthy we are so in
tackling the social determinants of
health it's housing it's Dec which is
environmental conservation it's a
permanent labor all of us working
together to figure out how to best
support wellness in this part of
Brooklyn of course we got the healthy
food portfolio and so we had a couple of
band-aid programs that I call them there
are great programs but they're they
weren't funded in perpetuity right
they're often for emergency food so
they're like they're helping but they're
not fundamentally transforming the kinds
of food that people have access to in
this part of Brooklyn one of the things
that came out of our first year of this
program was we had a lot of community
engagement the governor tasked us with
meeting with electeds meeting with our
local state assembly members who
represent these districts all of them
were asked to put together community
advisory councils to inform the
departments on how we can shift in and
sort of manipulate the program funding
that we had to make it really speak to
the local need and efforts that are
underway there out of those
conversations is actually where we found
out we had a lot of interest in food box
programming so great we went nuts with
that all over the city and we also were
told that we needed to fundamentally
it's serving central Brooklyn and so
from that we just wrapped up a year-long
feasibility study to see what it might
look like to build a food hub in central
Brooklyn one that is explicitly grounded
on the principles of racial equity and
is looking for opportunities to help
community owned businesses community led
initiatives from central Brooklyn to
have ownership stake in all of the work
that happens in this hub or along side
of it so we have no promise of funding
yet I don't have a happy ending story to
tell you about that other than we did
get money to do the feasibility study
and we're looking at it right now at the
state level to see if we can fund
something there but what a cool project
to be able to amass all of this
historical context and really think
about what building a better food system
for central Brooklyn would look like
okay so I was told
stop it 105 for questions I'm really
good at timing so we'll stop there feel
free to ask questions on any of the
stuff that I kind of took a deeper dive
into or some of the stuff that I
mentioned kind of high-level is a part
of our portfolio that we didn't really
get into research that's a good question
so yeah I was gonna say yeah for folks
who couldn't hear the question was we
know that the state provides grants to
nonprofits but what do you do for kind
of supporting small business incubation
the Department of Ag honestly doesn't
have a whole lot of that kind of funding
but we do have an economic development
agency that does provide some of that
funding so ESD Empire State Development
is our state version of that they do
yeah you're well familiar you're plugged
into their efforts already but they do a
lot of that funding on behalf of various
industries so we would go to them with
like we need some innovations in this
particular AG space let's create a
program and then they would administer
that funding our grant funding is for
the most part to nonprofits we fund
things like Lane
banks in addition to you know some of
the programs I call that here can you
talk a little bit more about the
proposed for central Brooklyn like would
that be aggregating food that was grown
in Brooklyn yeah so the question about
the food hub in Brooklyn is that to
aggregate food that's grown in Brooklyn
or how how would that work it's really
good question
so the answer is yes and we would love
it to play a role in aggregating food
from those who are growing in Brooklyn
particularly community gardens they
produce a lot of excess and since
they're not really able to sell
commercially in New York City it just
kind of goes to waste unless they can
get someone to schlep it over to a food
bank or a food pantry's so even just
having like some cold storage that's
available to those growers just help
like keep food viable for a little bit
longer is something that will probably
play a role somehow if and when we get
funded but the idea is really to
aggregate or to bring food down from and
from Long Island I shouldn't always say
down out in from Long Island down from
upstate to aggregate New York state
based growers what's particularly
interesting here is because this is a
community led process the conversations
we've been having which again we have
not been funded we have no idea of this
thing will ever even happen but people
are already like I want to buy from all
the black farmers in New York State
great not a lot of them are selling in
New York City we're actually losing
black farmers the latest census data is
really scary if you look at all of our
general types of farmers women farmers
latina X farmers regular like white old
guy farmers like they're all making more
and more money and they're all fine
black farmers are losing land and losing
revenue faster than anybody else so the
fact that you know now we have this
opportunity potentially to say we want
to steer our dollars in our demand to
support this subset of the industry
that's really struggling that's super
cool and very promising so do we have
enough of them to fill food hubs right
now probably not but could we start by
trying right that might be interesting
enough and then what we really came out
of the feasibility study is that a
single solitary building is not gonna
fix the food the food system it does not
fix right we there need to be other
pieces to it so what we are pitching is
something called a Hubbins
model where they're sort of a central
hub that's doing aggregation and
distribution of wholesale but then it
connects to like community-led retailers
so we there's a whole movement around
cooperative grocery stores right now in
that part of Brooklyn that was very red
there's actually three or four that have
organized and opened just in the last
couple of years and another one just got
a big federal grant to open and this is
because communities are taking all of
the reins of controlling where their
food you know what they're able to get
so those sorts of cooperatively owned
models are really appealing could we get
them into sort of an agreement with a
hub to purchase through them and help
pull the food out into communities is
there a role for an incubator kitchen to
help start food businesses and that part
of Brooklyn probably all this depending
on what we can get funding for other
[Laughter]
good question yeah yeah so the question
was about what's what's really the role
of government in moving like
incentivizing food to come into new
neighborhoods we did just go to Brooklyn
Brooklyn Wegmans and everybody in my
whole world is losing their minds over
it we're very excited I don't know how
much we did honestly like I would ask
the Commissioner that if he had any you
know talks to support or whatever I
don't really know we my team had nothing
to do with it
what I will say is that as much as I
love Wegmans one grocery store is not
going to serve all of Brooklyn and
there's still a lot of Brooklyn that
does not have access to a grocery store
it would take them over an hour to get
there we actually say you know there's
people are very familiar with the term
food desert and often times try to apply
that to the New York City context we are
not anywhere near a food desert there's
no such thing as a food desert in New
York City because of the definition no
one's more than a mile away from a
grocery store where food
swamp there's tons of food it's just bad
food there's food everywhere just making
us sick so in that sense I think that's
where the government role does come in
is finding pockets of like where does
the commercial industry itself not see
the opportunity to make a profit or the
community doesn't want the commercial
activity that's going to make a profit
because it's not serving their best
interests it's a swamp scenario rather
than you know getting the Wegmans that's
where we kind of come in with funding
some alternative models I think what
should I offer Geneva a chance
okay Geneva anyone with a question on
that end you mentioned that youth
engagement programs are not always well
connected to some traditional
agricultural resources and I was curious
what you see is the biggest barriers to
those connections and what you either
have done or think about doing to break
down some of those barriers
that's a great question I'm glad we get
to end on that one I think it's
literally just been distant like yeah
what that oh the question was about the
youth space and seeing lots of youth
activity happening in the city but not
plugging into some of the traditional
kind of youth and AG programs it exists
it's really just been that New York is a
big behemoth to navigate it's a scary
place to get off the train if you've
never really worked there and to find
your way around it's intimidating it's
really just been having the right people
in the right place I will say that the
current AG in the classroom team housed
at Cornell Katie
Derrick Hill who runs FFA all the folks
do in that work have been so excited to
have a team in based in Brooklyn that
knows these folks is excited about youth
work they've taken us taken up the
advantage many times to come down and
visit have introduced us to schools and
now we're starting to get connected to
schools who are coming up through that
sort of traditional AG ed piece and
saying we want an Ag educator here we
want to have a curriculum that teaches
agate but they don't know anything about
food justice so now it's starting to
come full circle where the agate folks
are saying hey can you go meet with this
pool talk about their curriculum they
want to start in FFA chapter one day
they don't know anybody that's doing
justice work great let's have this
conversation we can plug everyone in and
connect the dots what a good way to end
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu